what did I tell you what did I tell you
huh you kids out here with your Quantum
Iron Man and the Multiverse of garbage
right I mean this is sorry but this is
how you do action this
old school
come on you liked it
you liked it Tom Cruise I mean I don't
know how he does those stunts I mean
back when I was his age what
he's older than me well
really okay
all right uh I mean whatever that
Scientology business is right it seems
to be working for him huh right but
that's you know not not what we do no no
Scientology for us right no sorry nope
you know that Scientology is bad right
I'm just just I'm just making sure you
know because
because it's a joke
I could probably do some of those stunts
though I mean if I hit the gym if you
why are you laughing